i really don't think so he's blitzed out
26 the second time around
he's fine with the draw today no
but maybe hurt magnus
and remember to be a shark
queen f6
well maybe now after bishop c3 he will
be thinking
yeah but he carol can claim now like
would be strange to
to give napomnashy the choice no
but no he doesn't
sometimes also it's a pride thing no no
one wants to claim it look and look yeah
let's see if you're right that'd be
exciting if they repeat it three times
and look but
he thought he tells the armature
he thinks the game is over and it is and
the opponent she claims here and they
promise she claims
but he could have played on bishop c3
this is not how you claim a draw like
you just made the move in the press the
clocks on the publish is allowed to play
queen g5 dartmouth nobody claim it you
have to write down the move and call the
arbitrator yes
and we see the players
discussing after the game
there what has been gone wrong but
incredible that nakamura has so much
energy going back to his room and the
first thing is to make his
summary of this game
and i'm sure he will be very unhappy
discovering the things
the opportunities he missed and of
course he knows even though without
checking that he had a huge position
no